400 years ago galileo started piecing
together the basic principles of reality
what we now call modern science
but the questions he was trying to
answer are as old as humanity itself
what are we made of
what are the fundamental building blocks
of the universe from which you me the
stars and everything else is constructed
in the centuries since galileo thousands
of theories and experiments have peered
into smaller and smaller distances
converging on a single picture of the
structure of matter
this somewhat daunting looking formula
is where we end up
it gives the correct answer to hundreds
of thousands of experiments in some
cases with an accuracy that is
unprecedented in science
it is by any measure the most successful
scientific theory of all time
and yet for something so extraordinary
we give it a rubbish name
we call it the standard model
i'm david tong a theoretical physicist
at the university of cambridge
and in this video we're going to build
the standard model piece by piece
i hope that by the end you'll have some
intuition for how the different parts
fit together to create the fundamental
building blocks of our universe
this is the standard model
it describes how everything in the
universe is made of twelve different
types of matter particles interacting
with three forces all bound together by
a rather special particle called the
higgs boson
before we get going
some caveats
first i said three forces
while there are actually four
fundamental forces at play in the
universe this means there's something
missing from this picture and that
something would be gravity the most
obvious force at play in the world
around us and yet in many senses the one
that we understand least
we do have a theory of gravity a very
successful theory it was given to us by
albert einstein and it goes by the name
of general relativity but there are two
good reasons why it's not included in
the standard model
the first is that at the microscopic
level the force of gravity is so weak
that it barely has any effect on a
single subatomic particle
the second is that we don't really know
how to incorporate general relativity
which is a classical theory into the
quantum world we have no idea how to
peer into a black hole where quantum
gravity effects are clearly at work
a second caveat is that the standard
model is written in a language known as
quantum field theory this tells us that
mata at the fundamental level is not
really made up of particles instead it's
made up of fields fluid-like objects
which are spread throughout all of space
these fields are engaged in an intricate
harmonious dance to a music that we call
the laws of physics
the interactions between the fields
produce the physical world in the form
of particles
to understand the standard model it's
more convenient to use the language of
particles
as we build up the standard model we're
going to meet lots of particles with an
array of names that can very quickly
become bewildering but there's one
classification of particles that is by
far the most important
every particle
is either a fermion which is a matter
particle
or a boson which is a force particle
the distinction between fermions and
bosons lies in the quantum world
fermions must obey something that we
call the pauli exclusion principle
roughly speaking this means that you
can't put two fermions on top of each
other in space
as such these are the building blocks of
mata
[Music]
bosons on the other hand compile on top
of each other as much as they want
because they're not obliged to obey the
pauli exclusion principle
bosons are the particles that mediate
various forces and we'll talk about them
much more later
but for now let's start by looking at
the fermions
everything we're made of can be reduced
to just three mata particles
this is the electron and two species of
quarks that we call the up quark and the
downquark
the familiar proton and neutron each
contain three quarks
the proton has two up quarks and a down
while the neutron has two down quarks
and an up
put protons and neutrons together and
you have a nucleus
add electrons into the mix and you have
an atom
put a bunch of atoms together and that's
what we're made of
all the beauty and complexity that we
see in the world around us can be traced
to the same collection of three
particles rearranged over and over in
different combinations
next comes the fourth type of mata
particle it's called the neutrino and
it's not like the others
neutrinos are extremely light and barely
interact with anything else
for example in the time it took me to
say that something like a hundred
trillion neutrinos passed through your
body
most of them came from the sun
but millions of them have been streaming
uninterrupted through the universe since
the first few seconds after the big bang
[Music]
so there we have it four mata particles
three that make up you me and everyone
we know
and one very peculiar cosmic ghost
flowing through us all
but here's where things start to get
weird because nature didn't stop there
for reasons that we do not understand
she took this collection of four
particles and made two further copies
this means that there are actually three
different kinds of electron particles
in addition to the original electron
that we know and love there are
particles called the muon and the tau
the muon and the tau behave exactly like
an electron with one important exception
they're heavier
the muon is about 200 times heavier than
the electron the tau almost three and a
half thousand times heavier
the same generational pattern then
repeats for the quarks there are two
heavier versions of the down quark that
we call the strange
and bottom quarks and two heavier
versions of the up quark called charm
and top
and then there are also two more
neutrinos we become a little bit
unimaginative in our naming and call the
full collection the electron neutrino
the muon neutrino and the tau neutrino
now we don't see the second and third
generation of particles in everyday life
we can create these heavier particles
but they're unstable which means that
they quickly decay to the first
generation of particles that we're made
of
nonetheless we know they exist
we can detect them in particle
accelerators and in many cases we can
take photographs of the tracks they
leave behind
this is the collection of particles that
makes up our world
three sets of four
some of this we understand very well
in particular we understand why
particles have to come in a set of four
there's a mathematical consistency
condition in the standard model that
tells us you can't have one particle
without the other three
in contrast we don't understand at all
why there are three generations rather
than any other number that remains a
complete mystery
there is however a surprising aspect of
mathematical unity here all particles
are described by exactly the same
equation
this equation was written down in the
1920s by the physicist paul dirac
originally to describe the electron
but as we discovered more and more
particles we realized the dirac equation
or variance of it also describes them
so that's the stuff we're made of
but still we're missing something
crucial
we're missing the forces
without the forces the universe would be
boring
all the particles would wander around
the cosmos like lost souls never
interacting never doing anything
interesting
there are three fundamental forces in
the standard model electromagnetism the
strong force
and the weak force
each of these forces comes with an
associated particle
these particles are what we call bosons
the other half of our particle family
bosons are force-carrying particles
in one way of viewing things you can
think of the fermions as constantly
swapping bosons between them affecting
their motion and giving rise to what we
call a force
let's begin with the most familiar of
these forces
electromagnetism is responsible for the
chemical properties of the elements and
we've harnessed it to create much of
modern technology
it acts on anything that carries
electric charge that means that it acts
on the electron type particles and the
quarks but not on the neutrinos because
neutrinos are electrically neutral
an electron sitting still in space will
give rise to an electric field which
spreads radially outwards and attracts
or repels all other electrically charged
particles in its neighborhood
but if you look more closely at that
electric field you'll find that it's
comprised of the particles of
electromagnetism
these particles we call photons
next is the strongest fundamental force
in nature aptly named the strong force
this force acts only on quarks and
subsequently on particles like protons
and neutrons that are made of quarks
it's the strong force that holds
together the nuclei of atoms
it's also this force that is responsible
for nuclear fission
and gives the energy that is released in
an atomic explosion
just as the photon is associated to
electromagnetism there is a particle
associated to the strong force
we call it the gluon because it
literally sticks quarks together
as an electron gives rise to an electric
field so a quark sitting in space will
give rise to a gluon field but now
something different happens
unlike electromagnetism the field
doesn't spread out radially
instead the quark produces a thin flux
tube a string-like object which can only
end when it finds a different kind of
quark
this is what makes the strong force
strong
because the quarks are joined by a flux
tube it takes more and more energy to
pull them apart
this is why we never see quarks on their
own they're always bound together by the
strong force inside bigger particles
like protons and neutrons
the third and final force is the most
intricate and subtle of them all
this
is the weak force
like the strong force the weak force
acts only on subatomic distance scales
but rather than binding particles
together
the weak force is all about decay
we just learned that the strong force
binds quarks together to form protons
and neutrons creating the atomic nucleus
the weak force has the astonishing
ability to allow quarks to switch their
identity
a down quark can turn into an upquark
releasing an electron and a neutrino in
the process
this means that a neutron can morph into
a proton in what we call radioactive
beta decay
in this way the weak force is
responsible for the nuclear fusion
reactions that power the sun
and produce the energy required for life
on earth
[Music]
finally the weak force is also the
reason that heavier matter particles
quickly decay into the three lighter and
more stable fermions that make up matter
as we know it
there are particles associated to the
weak force and we call these the w and z
bosons
the weak force is the only one of the
three forces to act on all particles in
particular it's the only force that
neutrinos feel
finally it's time to meet the last piece
of the jigsaw the particle that in many
ways ties the whole standard model
together
[Music]
this
is the higgs boson
to explain why the higgs boson is so
special i should first tell you a
striking fact
none of the fundamental particles in the
world have a mass
this is where the higgs boson comes in
its role is to endow all fermions with a
mass
i'd love to be able to give you a clear
explanation for why this happens
but sadly it's difficult to come up with
good analogies for the higgs field
here's
what i would say is a so-so analogy
you should view the higgs field as
something like a cosmic molasses spread
throughout the universe trapping mata
particles as they travel through space
and giving them what appears to us to be
a mass
so this is the standard model 12 mata
particles interacting with three forces
and a higgs field
it's a beautiful picture the pinnacle of
400 years of science
but it's clear that the standard model
is not the last word in physics
since the discovery of the higgs boson
physicists like me feel that in many
ways the standard model is too
successful
it gives the right answer to every
experiment that we do
our current hope is that we'll
eventually find an experiment that it
gives the wrong answer to
and there are some hints that this is
happening
because only then can we get clues about
what lies beyond
one of the open questions about the
standard model is whether the three
fundamental forces are actually
different
or whether they are a manifestation of a
single all-encompassing force
this is the dream of a grand unified
theory
there are some theoretical signs that
this may be the way things work out but
so far no experimental confirmation
of course we're also left with the
obvious thing that's missing
and that's gravity
at the beginning of this video i talked
about the problem of quantum gravity
in recent years we've discovered
gravitational waves which are ripples of
space and time itself
and if we look closely there are good
reasons to believe that these waves are
made of quantum particles that we call
gravitons just like light waves are made
of photons
there are other things missing too the
standard model doesn't include the
invisible realm of dark matter and dark
energy which means that we're missing an
explanation for a whopping 95 percent of
the energy in the universe
dark matter is almost certainly made up
of additional particles that don't
interact with electromagnetism perhaps
these particles have their own forces
and their own messenger bosons
and there are still more questions about
the standard model that we just don't
know how to answer
why is the muon 200 times heavier than
the electron while the top quark is 350
000 times heavier than the electron why
is the neutrino a million times lighter
we have no idea we have no way of
predicting the masses of these particles
other than going out and measuring them
in experiments
but there are clearly patterns within
the masses of the particles which
strongly suggests that there's some
underlying structure just waiting to be
uncovered
the hope is that with experimental
results going hand in hand with new
theoretical ideas will ultimately be
able to reveal the next layer of reality
and understand what lies beyond the
standard model
until then we continue galileo's journey
with the ultimate goal
a theoretical framework to explain the
universe and everything in it
a theory
of everything
[Music]
you